nearly two minutes of opening credits to
prepare you for the end of this movie
before it even begins
remember 1985 when you could proudly
display mel gibson's name on a movie
with exciting music now when you think
of his name you practically hear the
music for Schindler's List does that's a
Tina Turner every step that you take the
day of I huh oh okay Tina Turner's
credited because of this song who she's
not actually acting in the movie after
all right right required two directors
to wrangle the ego Mel Gibson they never
let poor Rudolph play in any Camel games
also Mad Max has been dealing with this
post-apocalyptic bullshit for two other
movies and he's somehow not on alert for
thieves and can't hear airplanes as they
approach I guess the woman this guy was
dating in the road warrior agreed to
breed with him my question is why take
her kid to work day north by max West
monkey knows its master needs Footwear
so he pushes convenience off the cart I
guess Mel Gibson was William Wallace ten
years before Braveheart in case you
confused it with jacked up prices you
have no choice but to pay town high Joe
and I go this movie is basically the
opposite of Waterworld Waterworld is a
discount opposite this movie complete
with the guy in an umbrella hat damn
this guy's card is so radioactive it's
amazing everyone who goes near it hasn't
gotten instant cancer or superpowers
discount Kevin Spacey with a discount
future Michael Jackson masks the guards
here have no long-range weapons and go
through so much that Raiders of the Lost
Ark that whoever they're trying to
protect would be dead before they got
finished showing off later max will have
to give up his guns before he goes
further into barter town maybe they
should have the gun checked before they
get to this point right okay that's all
the weapons I promise no need to Pat me
down for hidden ones because clearly I
only had room for 10 guns homoerotic
elevating diaper saxophone oh god they
gave her a speaking role also either
Tina Turner's distracting me during this
Mad Max movie or this Mad Max movie is
distracting me from Tina Turner either
way I'm damn distracted dammit the
director said let's have you eat an
apple to start a fight it'll make you
look like even more of an asshole
the fate of Kevin Spacey Michael Jackson
mask guy is left to the imaginations of
the audience it looks like it falls down
into a hole or something but there's no
hole to fall into so I am confused
congratulations
the first survive the audition and the
other people who tried this must have
been really bad at fighting also how
many people have actually gotten this
far
max had to threaten the collector and
shoot this one guards hair before he was
even allowed up here so how bad is
security in the bartering place oh he
did fall down into that open area there
and he survived key aspects of this room
were only revealed to us just now up to
my on hits in glad - Tina's character
slips into describing Tina's real-life
marriage with Ike call it under well
roll crit oh wait
swept out of town gets his energy what
all natural guess pigs Jesus how vague
are you going to be until you finally
tell us the energy comes from pigs
master-blaster they're a unit they even
share the same name the little one is
called master ok look I'm fine with
calling this guy Master Blaster but
don't tell me that one guy's named
master and the other one blaster when
you just told me they share the same
name that's like calling them Brangelina
or Bennifer and saying they share the
same name is this the first time Master
Blaster noticed the big periscope spying
on them down here you can shovel can't
you well the movie certainly can factory
how long are you in for the big one like
that is funny it's a class job one
mistake it'll blow the crap out of this
place literally thing what to know this
is the brains of the operation I'll
disconnect the bathroom I wouldn't do
that if I were you
there's no world in which Mad Max could
hear this conversation in a loud Pig
Factory especially when he couldn't hear
that plane that stole his stuff earlier
oh sure that's way liver
Max is allowed to be a smartass in the
situation hey that's racist right father
Tao master blaster flash even the master
blaster has embargoed the power many
times and has made her admit who runs
the town many times he makes auntie say
this over the loudspeaker this time
probably because max is in the plot now
luckily Master Blaster has a horrible
weakness when it comes to high-pitched
noises and Max brought his whistle with
him which was luckily pushed out of the
carriage by the monkey earlier in the
movie and Adele so everything Beyond
Thunderdome is basically this city right
it sounds cool when you hear the title
but it's basically just a way to save
Bartertown
two men into one
and leaves crowd has to remind
themselves off the one rule Thunderdome
has it's a man with no name so I guess
Max is the good aunty is the bad and
Master Blaster is the ugly where's Eli
want like when you need to settle this
you gotta admit this is a horrible way
to enjoy sports Bartertown built an
entire murder cage but couldn't build
decent seating to watch the fight max
avoids an unavoidable spike seeing that
the spike thing didn't work just that
one time blaster decides to go for the
much more difficult jumping on max
technique to kill him I just want
everyone to know that this movie's
entire plot rests on a monkey throwing
some out of Max's carriage at the
beginning one of those things with a
lucky whistled that just happens to be
blasters weakness morals Oh No look at
his face how the fuck did Master get
inside Thunderdome no more meth raid
this place
Freddie I know you're arrogant but
couldn't you wait until you got outside
the Thunderdome and back into the
underworld before making this threat
no no manager one mans
yeah but what does this mantra actually
mean when a third man runs inside I'm
still trying to figure out how I even
got in there
I mean he's small but he's not
Thunderdome whole small when I wrong
we had a deal and the law says bust a
deal face the wheel which is an offshoot
of article 6 section 302 of the barter
town law He Who smelt it dealt it Jesus
do these assholes have to chant every
law one of the places this wheel can
land on is a spin again choice
considering that none of those choices
on this wheel are good why even bother
with that or is it a joke damn it might
be a joke while I was hanging by a
thread this assholes like the Chuck
Woolery of Bartertown weight they drag
this wheel all the way in here what the
hell for how did this mother fit through
the door did they assemble it inside the
pudding of the dude into the gulag
ceremony must wait for daytime and yet
all spectators from the previous night's
Thunderdome fight will still be
interested enough to show back up and
spectate again I know the movie doesn't
respect this character but it's
beginning to feel like the movie doesn't
even respect this actor what is this
tunnel for no one really knows but it
comes in super handy when you need to
send a monkey out to run errands movie
inspires future Canadian pop star douche
bag on how to best stitches monkey now
with its world-renowned tracking skills
monkey will find a guy riding on a horse
through the desert with a 12 hour head
start I don't understand the punishment
wheel landed on Gulag which is a prison
camp or a forced labor camp in the
Soviet Union but they basically banished
him hoping he would die I guess this is
mighty disrespectful of a wheel for
which you have created a chant how did
the prisoner guy who sent the monkey get
that sweet sweet h2o in a wineskin
inside the pig prison thankfully this
desert wasteland Google Ag punishment
also contains a ferry rescue godmother
NH was 16 where this movie came out so
and hey she's a discount this chick it's
him I find him you mean you're actually
looking for max and he has some sort of
history with your drive that will
confuse us and him for the next ten
minutes ah the Society of creepy
children damn Max's in such bad shape as
clothes turned blue
hair theft damn falling out of the
hospital must happen so much they tie
ropes around patients legs just in case
maybe the hospital shouldn't be in such
an elevated position I don't know why
discount lost bone he thinks he's
actually in Peter Pan EMU had Mad Max
Beyond Thunderdome decided you know what
the Ewoks weren't so bad let's do our
own Ewok scene without the Ewoks
remember this I have a feeling I'll be
screaming with delight about this movie
in two weeks
I even plan on asking for my ticket this
way one ticket to tomorrow-morrow land
please and much like the people in this
movie worshiped a flying bird known as
an airplane we will worship Brad Bird in
all his magnificence man I hope that
movie is good this sin won't seem like a
sin at all
so this tribe thinks max is Captain
Walker based on almost nothing except I
found a Rando dude in the desert and
he's white crazy wind starts blowing so
that this entire tribe can get excited
about captain walker's airplane and max
can reveal to these kids there's no
Santa Claus a second time damn I'm
jealous to be completely fair these kids
are probably eating apples for
much-needed nourishment but they're
still kind of assholes the first place
you'll find is a sleaze pit cold battle
now if the earth doesn't swallow you up
first that place sure as hell will we
are Beyond Thunderdome here people max
punches this woman because she wants to
leave this place sure he's saving her
life but this is her choice man you've
gone from not caring about anybody in
the last movie in the beginning of this
movie to all the sudden caring what
people do this is against his character
but yay for the punchy hero today also
that's racist
how does max expect these people that
keep Savannah tied up for the rest of
the night as soon as he falls asleep
somebody sympathetic is going to weigh
the loyalty of knowing someone all their
life against knowing someone for three
hours I need as much water as I can
carry it's not going to be easy
defeating freedom of choice but god damn
it I will go to the ends of the earth to
do it movie tries to challenge Lawrence
of Arabia's record for walking in the
desert scenes well now they've
experienced firsthand two of the great
dangers of the fire swamp where is it
out there wait a minute so these other
kids went into the underworld where they
have no clue what the situation is with
no plan or anything that's a wonder
these guys aren't dead already
this guy manages to hit all the non
target space around his target
well somebody saw Star Wars oh yeah a
tina turner's in this movie i completely
forgot
since we've been beyond thunderdome for
40 minutes now also oh no my incredibly
bizarre punishment didn't work I'm going
to have to take the wheels name in vain
now wheel damn it now that I've got you
where I can kill you time to gloat for a
second so you can get saved the fact
anyone hears her so bleeped they're a
perfectly good train track still intact
after all these years general nature
would have taken care of this not to
mention all the thieves looking to
profit from the medal they could steal
what kind of post-apocalypse is this I
assure you that even if this record
player could still play records that the
record it's playing would definitely not
sound like this it's warped cracked and
dirty it would sound worse than the Hal
9000 when that dick astronaut pulled his
memory cards the last time we saw this
guy he did a bit tan and into a tub of
pigs so when did he have a chance to
clean that off this cow car is straight
out of death race 2000 now see this car
chase action set piece is what everyone
who came to see this movie expected to
see only they were expecting it before
the final 15 minutes and probably
neither expected nor wanted the hour and
a half Peter Pan Blue Lagoon Bulls they
just sat through it this guy got rammed
into by a train and there was a fiery
explosion shortly after that the fact
that iron bar is still alive makes me
angry max Steel's an entire human being
from an T as if she were Jim McMahon
handing off to Walter Payton this cat is
on his 12th life already
also maybe there's a time where you
decide you know what I don't need this
Michael Jackson accessory anymore even
when it should be burned completely
beyond recognition to this ball
sudden bridge shows up out of nowhere
now come on
even Fast Five knew to show us when a
bridge was coming up as ridiculous as
that movie is oh you little kid how did
you get out here and build that mound of
dirt and time to stop the train even if
you flew out here you didn't have the
time unless you have mounds of dirt just
lying around for this occasion wait are
we now to believe that they built a
mound of dirt just on the off chance
that someone would run a train on it
again and the kid was outside just
waiting for that very thing to occur
also this is perfect timing his dad has
a plane and can save the day airplane
that is built for small cargo will now
be able to fit eight extra people and
become a clown car when it comes to
space max was the last one on this plane
but he managed to slip by seven other
people in tight quarters to get right
behind jebediah movie thinks we like
this guy so much we'll be thrilled every
time he shows up after clearly dying in
a previous scene even if he didn't die I
don't know he caught up to the rest of
Andy's crew
don't worry iron bar I'm sure you're
okay after that how does that create a
clear flat runway surface wait if he can
take off there why did max need to crash
his truck what the fuck is going on iron
bars middle finger is not to max but the
audience well ain't we up a raggedy man
that's it you went from no mercy to haha
well you ruined my city but damn it I
respect you this you knows the years
travel fast
epilogue narration
your very own rare camel what job they
spit
direct from out of the wasteland is bad
is beautiful is crazy
it's amazing spider-man
you